i think it's the first time that i felt
so
personally happy like my career has
always made me super happy performing
has made me super happy but
for the first time personally i am like
whoa
happiness it's so cool it's so awesome
if you don't know jojo siwa by her
iconic ponytail 3.6
billion youtube views or her recent
coming out as lgbtq
ask any tween or preteen and they will
definitely
know her story yes the 17 year old is
finally living life as her authentic
self and in a brand new people cover
story
jojo opened up about her decision to
come out to the world
and why she still doesn't 100 want to
put a label on her sexuality
technically i would say that i am
pansexual because that's how i have
always been my whole life
is just like my human is my human but
you know i still i still really don't
have a final answer on that and i don't
know if i ever will you know it's
something that just kind of floats
around and
i'm living my life and that's just it's
it is what it is it is what's happening
despite the fact jojo wished she hadn't
looked at comments on social media
after coming out she quickly found
clarity
a lot of them were i'm never buying your
merch again my daughter is never
watching you again
this and that and this and that and the
other things
and my thing is is i don't want people
like that to watch my videos i don't
want people to buy my merchandise
if they aren't gonna support not only me
but the lgbtq community for more of
jojo's candid interview
make sure you head to peopletv.com or
download the free
people tv app
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos